hey and welcome to this special edition
of Hannity and tonight an important
warning about the Democrat Party
traditional liberals moderates they no
longer have a place in the party that
they once called their home far left
authoritarians have now taken over and
now they're using the Democratic party
as a vessel to destroy our Great
American way of life they don't believe
in Freedom or individualism as much as
they claim or on inalienable rights
instead they prefer government mandated
collectivism for them the Bill of Rights
is just standing in the way in the name
of quote common good they want to
control where you live how you travel
what you eat what you wear what you
drive and of course what you're allowed
to think and what you're allowed to say
and God forbid you say the wrong thing
and they want to force you or shame you
to follow their health care demands they
want to eliminate self-defense
self-reliance and force everyone to
comply with Mother government and
according to these Democrats well they
are going to do all of this for your own
good thank goodness they're in your life
in order to achieve this left-wing
Utopia they are using even our
department of justice to enforce their
radical Vision First by squashing any
and all dissent God forbid you speak out
at a school board meeting you know
another example the political
persecution of Donald Trump far beyond
anything this country has ever seen it's
never happened in history before now
first they attempted to destroy his
presidency over a real conspiracy theory
hoax now he's facing hundreds of years
behind bars because of a variety of
far-fetched overreaching indictments all
timed for maximum political impact and
the lead-up to a presidential election
at the very same time the doj is
seemingly ignoring you know very real
evidence of corruption possible bribery
money laundering against President Joe
Biden in other words Biden's weaponized
doj trying to in prison is Chief
political rival all the while giving Joe
a free pass that is what you see in a
far left Banana Republic or in the old
Soviet Union uh political enemies they
get locked up they get silence those in
charge they live privileged Lifestyles
no rules at all ever wonder how Joe
Biden affords uh two lavish residences
in Delaware despite his life in public
service the far left Department of
Justice doesn't seem to care they're not
curious at all that's because his last
name is Biden and not Trump or Clinton
in the case of Clinton or Biden or Trump
you know the difference and the bidens
are always willing to tow the party line
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else